president trump is ready to resume
public appearances to make up for lost
time from his bout with the coronavirus
despite lingering questions about his
health the president is expected to host
his first event at the white house today
since testing positive for the virus it
comes two weeks
after president trump announced judge
amy coney barrett as his supreme court
nominee
during a crowded white house rose garden
ceremony dr anthony fauci the nation's
top infectious disease expert
now calls that a super spreading event
chip reid is
at the white house this morning with
more chip good morning well good morning
president trump is planning to hit the
campaign trail again
monday with a rally in florida but his
first public event
since testing positive will be here at
the white house this afternoon hundreds
of people are expected to attend and
some medical experts are already
predicting
that this could become another super
spreader event
i feel really good i feel very strong in
an
interview on fox news friday night
president trump said he had completed
his course of covid
therapeutics and described his early
symptoms as mild
it didn't feel strong didn't feel really
strong i didn't have a problem with
breathing
which a lot of people seem to have i had
none of that
but i didn't feel very strong i didn't
feel very vital
i didn't feel like the president of the
u.s should feel
and i knew there was something a little
bit off but earlier in the day the
president told rush
limbaugh he was so sick last week he
thought
he might not make it this looks like it
was going to be a big deal and
and you know what that means right that
means bad the president says he
recovered quickly because he had
immediate access to the doctors
and the treatments we have white house
doctor who's
great and you have so many great doctors
so it's a lot easier for me than
somebody that's
you know not doesn't have access to a
doctor so easily where it's a big deal
to see a doctor
the president insists he's good to go
but the white house has yet to disclose
if he has tested negative for the virus
which would indicate he's no longer
contagious
while campaigning in nevada on friday
former vice president
joe biden called the president's
behavior reckless
his reckless personal conduct since his
diagnosis
the stabilizing effect it's having on
our government is unconscionable
he didn't take the necessary precautions
to protect himself
or others when asked about mr trump's
planned return to the campaign trail
the democratic nominee said this good
luck
i make sure i wouldn't show up unless
you had a mask for a distance
as you mentioned michelle the second
presidential debate has now
officially been canceled and the trump
campaign is blaming the debate
commission
they say that they are biased in favor
of
joe biden even though it is a bipartisan
commission
michelle how about that chiffried thank
you so much